FAVOR OF THAT REMOVAL.
>> Juan: WAIT A MINUTE, WE
JUST HAD A FOX POLL...
>> Dagen: AVERAGE.
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP LEGAL
TEAM ON THE SENATE FLOOR RIGHT
NOW MAKING THE CASE AGAINST
IMPEACHMENT, AS YOU KNOW.
THIS COMES AS THE FIGHT OVER
WITNESSES AND TESTIFIES YET
AGAIN.
THIS TIME, IT’S OVER CLAIMS OF
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
JOHN BOLTON’S NEW BOOK.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
THAT IN AN UNPUBLISHED
MANUSCRIPT, BOLTON ALLEGES THAT
THE PRESIDENT TIED AID TO
UKRAINE TO THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE BIDENS.
THE REPORT BUILDING A NEW BATTLE
OVER TESTIMONY AMONG LAWMAKERS.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT DENYING
JOHN BOLTON’S CLAIMS EARLIER
TODAY.
>> I HAVEN’T SEEN THE MANUSCRIPT
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT NOTHING
WAS EVER SAID TO JOHN BOLTON.
BUT I HAVE NOT SEEN THE
MANUSCRIPT.
I GUESS HE’S WRITING A BOOK.
I’M NOT SURE.
>> Juan: DANA, LET ME ASK YOU.
DO YOU THINK THIS MOVES THE
NEEDLE ON REPUBLICANS VOTING TO
CALL WITNESSES?
>> Dana: IF POSSIBLE.
IT’S POSSIBLE.
BUT I THINK WE’VE GOT A WAYS TO
GO BEFORE YOU EVEN GET TO A VOTE
ABOUT WITNESSES, YOU HAVE
ANOTHER TWO MAY BE EVEN A DAY OR
SO, DEPENDS HOW MUCH TIME THE
PRESIDENT’S LAWYERS WANT TO USE.
IT COULD, BUT MAYBE WE’LL FIND
OUT MORE ABOUT THIS BEFORE THEN.
EVEN IF WE DO GET TO WITNESSES,
AS POINTED OUT MOMENTS AGO, YOU
CAN GET TO A POINT WHERE IT’S
CLEAR THERE’S GOING TO BE
WITNESSES AND ALL THE WITNESSES.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE JUST JOHN
BOLTON, MICK MULVANEY.
IT’S GOING TO BE -- YOU WON’T
GET TO DO THE NO WITNESSES LIKE
THE HOUSE DEAD
DEAD.
AS FAR AS I KNOW, JOHN BOLTON, I
WAS HIS SPOKESPERSON WHEN I
WAS -- WHEN THE PRESIDENT
APPOINTED HIM TO THE
UNITED NATIONS AND THE DEMOCRATS
BLOCKED THAT.
CAUGHT HIM A LIAR AND ALL SORTS
OF THINGS.
NOT CALLING HIM A LIAR NOW.
I’M FOR PEOPLE WRITING BOOKS,
BUT I’VE ALSO LONG BELIEVED THAT
THE BEST WAY TO WRITE A BOOK IF
YOU’VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY AND A
PRIVILEGE TO WORK AND
ADMINISTRATION IS TO DO SO AFTER
A TERM IS OVER.
EITHER WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS NO
LONGER THE PRESIDENT, I THINK
FOLKS IN THE MIDDLE OF IT IT
LOOKS FOR PERSONAL GAIN AND THEY
ARE ALWAYS TAKEN THE WRONG WAY
AND THEY HURT THE VERY PERSON
WHO GAVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECAUSE THE MEDIA WILL ALWAYS
TRY TO FIND A WAY TO SEE IF
THERE IS A WAY TO DIVIDE.
I PREDICTED THIS ON FRIDAY, I
WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF BY
SUNDAY NIGHT THERE IS ANOTHER
ONE OF THESE LITTLE LEAKS
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS REALIZE
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THIS
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE
ACQUITTED BUT THEY ARE GOING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM AS MUCH AS
THEY POSSIBLY CAN AND THIS
HAPPENS ON SUNDAY NIGHT.
HERE’S WHAT I WOULD ALSO SAY.
THAT MIGHT BE WRONG, BUT THE
WHITE HOUSE, ANY WHITE HOUSE,
HAS TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET
MUCH MORE COORDINATED.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO KNOW THAT,
OH, HEADS UP, EVERYBODY, JOHN
BOLTON’S MANUSCRIPT LANDED IN
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNSEL’S
DESK, WHO NEEDS TO BE THERE TO
KNOW ABOUT IT?
THEY DIDN’T DO ABOUT IT FOR IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY DIDN’T KNOW
ABOUT IT, IT LOOKS LIKE THEY
WERE CAUGHT A LITTLE BIT
FLAT-FOOTED TODAY.
>> Juan: DAGEN, ONE THING THAT
STRIKES ME PICKING UP ON WHAT
DANA SAID IN HER ACCURATE
PREDICTION, WE HAD THE LEV
PARNAS THING COME OUT, WE’VE HAD
THE OMB EMAIL ABOUT THE MONEY
BEING WITHHELD AFTER THE PHONE
CALL.
WE HAVE THE GAO THING THAT’S AS
IT WAS ILLEGAL.
NOW WE’VE GOT BOLTON AND HE’S
NAMING NAMES?
IT’S LIKE A DRIP, DRIP, DRIP.
>> Greg: EXACTLY!
>> Dagen: WHERE DO YOU GO...
DO YOU KNOW WHY WE ARE LAUGHING?
>> Juan: TELL ME.
>> Dagen: YOU TELL HIM.
>> Jesse: IT’S OBVIOUSLY A
COORDINATED STUNNED, JUAN.
>> Juan: WAIT, BOLTON AND HIS
LAWYERS...
>> Jesse: HERE’S WHY I’M NOT
BUYING THIS BOLTON STUFF.
I’VE BEEN HERE LONG ENOUGH TO
KNOW IT’S NOT A HATCHET
IT’S A HATCHET JOB.
HOW MANY TIMES RELEVANT BEEN
LEAKED PERFECTLY TIMED TO HELP
THE DEMOCRATS TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
>> Dagen: JIM COMEY!
>> Juan: ARE THESE THE SAME
SOURCES THAT SAID THERE WAS
RUSSIAN COLLUSION?
ARE THESE THE SAME ANONYMOUS
PEOPLE IN THE NSA WHO TRIED TO
DRAG HIS WHOLE WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT?
>> Greg: WE DON’T KNOW WHO
LEAKS IT.
WE KNOW WHY.
THE TIMING TELLS YOU WHY, IN
ORDER TO NAIL THE PRESIDENT.
BUT WHAT YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND
IS NOBODIES ACTUALLY SEEING THE
ACTUAL QUOTE.
>> Dagen: COULD DEFEND THE
ACTUAL PRESIDENT!
>> Greg: PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT
ARE FREAKING OUT ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE IT VINDICATES TRIM
BECAUSE IT TELLS EVERYBODY WHAT
TRUMP REALLY THOUGHT IT’S THAT
UKRAINE WAS CORRUPT AND ON
BEHALF OF THE DEMS, BUT IT’S
LIKE ANOTHER BOMB SHELL.
THE MEDIA HAS TBD, TERMINAL
BOMBSHELL.
DISEASE.
>> Jesse: THEY LIED ABOUT WHAT
THEY SAID THEIR ELEVATION IS.
THEY DO NOT GET TO PAGE FOUR
UNTIL THEY TELL YOU THE MEAT OF
THE CONVERSATION THAT BOLTON HAD
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS A DIRECT QUOTE FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE GOOD
STUFF.
HE, THE PRESIDENT, "PREFERRED
SENDING NO ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE
UNTIL OFFICIALS HAD TURNED OVER
ALL THE MATERIALS THEY HAD ABOUT
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION THAT
RELATED TO MR. BIDEN AND
SUPPORTERS OF MRS. CLINTON AND
UKRAINE."
THIS WAS NOT ABOUT BURISMA OR
HUNTER, THIS WAS ABOUT THEM
RELEASING INFORMATION ABOUT
ELECTION INTERFERENCE AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT THERE THAT’S WHY
THIS MURKY LEAK WAS PROBABLY
FROM SOME GUY THAT SAW A
MANUSCRIPT, SPUN IT TO THE
TIMES, AND THEY CAN CORROBORATE
BECAUSE THEY DON’T HAVE IT.
>> Dana: CAN I MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION ABOUT SOMETHING?
>> Dagen: I WAS GOING TO SAY
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
>> Dana: I NEVER HAVE THOSE.
I THINK WHEN YOU DO A BOOK IN
THE MIDDLE OF -- ESPECIALLY IF
YOU HAD TOP-SECRET CLEARANCE,
YOU HAVE TO GET IT CLEARED FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVEN’T CLEARED IT, BUT THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES HAS
THE ABILITY TO CLEAR IT IF HE
WANTS TO.
THEY COULD RELEASE THAT CHAPTER
OR THEY COULD TELL JOHN BOLTON,
WE ARE GOOD WITH YOUR BOOK,
WHATEVER, THEY COULD RELEASE IT,
AND TRYING TO DO THAT BEFORE
THIS QUESTION --
>> Greg: HE WAS ON AMAZON
TODAY.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO?
>> Dana: HAS TO DO WITH THE
PUBLISHER.
>> Juan: THEY CATEGORICALLY
STATE THEY ABSOLUTE HE HAD NO
COORDINATION WITH IT.
BUT I WILL POINT THIS OUT, IF
YOU THINK THAT YOUR AUTHOR IS
GOING TO GIVE AWAY WHAT’S IN THE
BOOK, YOU NEED TO PRESELL THAT
BOOK EXPLETIVE BEFORE HE
ACTUALLY TESTIFIES POTENTIALLY.
THIS IS YOU STRIKING WHILE THE
IRON IS HOT AND THIS IS THE
MOMENT.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS NOT NUMBER
ONE, KOBE BRYANT IS NUMBER ONE.
THEY TRY TO SELL IT AHEAD.
>> Juan: IS NO QUESTION, HE
TIED PRESIDENT TRUMP TO A QUID